[Applauso]
non me ne frega niente se loro mamme se
ne sbattono i [ __ ] e devi fare lo
Slime io tutta la notte non sei un
disadattato come loro va bene ti ho
cresciuto con i miei principi con dei
valori Cotugno ti ho pagato la scuola
americana se vuoi vivere sotto questo
tetto ti devi rispettare le mie regole
se no te ne vai a lavorare eh
non ti do mai più un euro Non fare il
fenomeno con tua madre eh perché come ti
ho creato ti distruggo pure il motorino
la PlayStation alla paghetta a tutto
quello che ti ho sempre dato Marco
Tullio Adesso prendo va in Giove arriva
quella cazzo di festa e gli faccio
passare la voglia di fare il fenomeno
davanti a tutti i tuoi amici ciao